[Applause]
Princess Ariel we know that you and your
father don't talk much but did you ever
think about asking him about your family
tree we did some digging on your behalf
and quickly uncovered some very puzzling
clues did you know that you have uncles
and and cousins who are more godly than
human if you thought your father was
overprotective before wait until you
hear what he's been hiding from you all
these years
[Music]
The Little Mermaid might just have the
most messed up family tree out of all
the Disney Princesses and we're about to
prove it keep watching to find out why
Ariel has more in common with Maui than
any other Disney character Queen Athena
like many other Disney Princess stories
Ariel's childhood was riddled with loss
and hardships much about Ariel's mother
Queen Athena was left to the imagination
but that all changed in 2008 when Disney
released The Little Mermaid
Ariel's beginning it's here that we find
out that Queen Athena tragically passed
away when she was hit with a big pirate
ship when Ariel was just a kid Queen
Athena's demise is what fueled King
Triton's hatred for humans
coincidentally Ariel ended up falling
for a human and saving him when his boat
capsized
Ariel's family tree was shaken right off
the bat and it only gets more messed up
as the apples start falling out King
Triton at first glance King Triton is
the rightful ruler of Atlantica but when
you swim a little deeper you find out
that Triton's father is the one who set
him up with the job in Greek mythology
Triton is a sea god of waves and calm
seas and he's the son of Poseidon
whenever the demigod Triton is depicted
artistically he's always given a mer
man's body and both Triton and his
father carry a trident so while many of
us simply thought that Ariel's dad was a
king it turns out that he's a demigod as
well oddly enough in Greek mythology
Athena actually served as Titans foster
child instead of his wife princess
melody Princess Ariel is very different
than the other Disney Princesses
mushiya mermaid but she's also a mother
in the Little Mermaid to return to the
sea were introduced to princess melody
she's smart adventurous and somewhat of
a tomboy and she's every bit her
mother's daughter craving the ocean like
a fresh breath of air melody strikes a
deal with the sea witch Morgana
by the end of the movie it's clear that
melody wants to live in Atlantica with
her grandfather so just when we thought
Ariel was going to get a happily ever
after her young daughter jumped ship and
became everything her mother never
wanted to be auntie Ursula just when we
thought that Ariel's family tree
couldn't get any more messed up we've
realized that Disney originally intended
for Ursula to be Ariel's and ultimately
Disney chose against making King Triton
and Ursula brother and sister however
they did leave a major clue in the
original film that could be used to
prove their lineage their possible
brother and sister relationship is
hinted at when Ursula speaks at a time
when she and Triton lived in the same
palace so Ariel's family tree has both
gods and sea witches ingrained into it
you would think that Ursula would have
been a little nicer to her youngest
niece but once a sea witch always a sea
witch great-uncle Zeus and Hades since
Disney chose to put auntie Ursula on the
back burner we're going to focus on King
Triton's mythological roots if you look
at Triton's family tree you quickly find
out that Zeus is his father's brother so
this makes loose none other than Ariel's
great-uncle
but since Ariel's grandfather Poseidon
has three sons in total this also means
that Hades is Ariel's great-uncle as
well
you know I know I got it I got the
concept is it just us or is Ariel's
family tree jam-packed with some of the
most powerful God's of all time
Ariel's cousins now that we know that
Ariel's great uncle's are none other
than Zeus and Hades we can finally
confirm the relation between Hercules
and Ariel
these two main characters are second
cousins despite coming from very
different worlds if we dig a little
deeper we also realize that Princess
Ariel ends now from descendants our
cousins as well after all she is Hades
daughter right who we'd love to see
Ariel Hercules and now getting together
for a royal family reunion but that's
probably not going to happen anytime
soon that is unless mal finds out who
her father is in descendants three and
connects the dots quarter God Princess
Ariel by now we're all well aware that
princess Ariel's lineage dates all the
way back to Greek mythology she's a
daughter of a demigod making her a
quarter God and putting her on the same
spectrum as Maui from Moana while it
makes perfect sense that Ariel can
breathe underwater and communicate with
her fellow mermaids her abilities go
beyond that Ariel's got superhuman
strength durability speed and
adaptability in the bag and she owes
this all to her grandfather Poseidon who
is a full-on God despite only having a
quarter of his powers Ariel is extremely
powerful and she doesn't even know it
she could give her puns ulm awana and
Elsa are run for their money okay well
maybe not Elsa but she's in a league of
her own so there you have it guys the
truth about the little mermaids messed
up family tree were you shocked to find
out that Hercules mal and Ariel were
actually second cousins let us know how
you feel about Ariel's lineage in the
comment section below
and that's a wrap like and subscribe to
the things so you never miss another
video thanks for watching we'll see you
next time
[Music]